[Music]
Laughter Laughter Laughter
He was affected by the war. He needs this support. He needs
you to forget his fear and hello.
[Music]
Right now, they were in the hospital and the day before yesterday they were having a good time.
My mother and father had nothing wrong with it, but my father.
Today we were very happy and they threw a party for us. The clown,
the doctor and the rabbit came back and we played. We played.  We were very
happy
[music] A
doctor who is the one who delivers a message to children
in an indirect way,
specific health messages.
How does a person feel when there is an
earthquake, God forbid. How can he protect himself? How can he not get hurt as much as possible? They found an outlet, so they can explode
what is in their heart. Praise be to God. They rejoiced and laughed
[  [Music]
I
swear they were very happy, but it was all for the
little ones, even the fear that we had was gone, and I
hope that every day comes and
celebrates like this, and there is an impact on the children. We
find it in gigantic laughter. This is the most important thing
for us right now.